コメント欄っていうのがありますよね？
はい。　見ます？
たまーにね？
批判されてたらどうです？
それは悲しいよね
そういうことだ！
いや、そうゆう事が言いたいわけじゃなくてですね
動画を出すとYouTubeってコメント欄っていうところがあって
戦闘…コメント。意見とか楽しかったとか言うわけなんですけども
コメント欄って一番上に来るのが見られるじゃん
あれって、どうゆう順番になってるか知ってる？
コメント順ではないの…？
コメント順じゃなくて、コメントの評価が高い順っていうか
一番見られたり、リアクションされてるコメントが一番上に来てるんです
一番ホットなやつが、一番上に来てるわけでございます
と、言うわけで今回は
動画の1番上のコメントはなんじゃろうな選手権
まぁ
僕ぐらいのねYouTube博士になると
どのコメントがね、こう、なんか、流れがあるわけですよ
アルゴリズムがあって、だいたい僕が掴んでるわけですよ、そのアルゴリズムを
こうゆう動画にはこうゆうコメントがくるな
どうゆうコメントが、こうなんか話題になるか、結構わかるんですよ
なんで、今回は、適当に僕の動画を選んでもらって
その動画の一番上のコメントを、何かを、僕が
一字一句間違えずに当てます
おーっ　完璧に
いや一字一句は無理だな…
一字一句はやめよう。何かニュアンスが合ってたら…
ニュアンス当てます！
当てれるまで、終われまテン
2160個の磁石ボールで何ができるのか？
あーっ、磁石ボ―ル2160個か
まぁ率直な僕の意見から言いますと
「もったいない」とかが多い気がするな
何だろうなー
何だと思う？
この後何に使うの？
ああああっ
このコメントにグッドした人は明日告白される
果たして正解は！
オレじゃねえか
今日の照明の感じどう？変えたんだけど
ちょっと待って…
そっか、自分の可能性もあるのか！
ちなみに、その次のコメントが
ひとりかくれんぼ動画みた後怖くなって逃げてきた
関係ねえなぁあんまり…
検証、成人男性何人で重なるジャンプ倒せるのか？
あーっ、なるほど、なるほどね
あー難しいな
ジャンプを破ってるんでしょ確か
いやーこれ難しいね
ジャンプもったいない
ジャンプもったいないか…
ジャンプいつも読んでる人グッドボタン
じゃあ見てみましょう
フフフ…
また本人ですね
本人のVジャンプ欲しい
所沢を真空状態にしてみた
あっー
もう、どっちかクリアしたらやめよう
うん。　これちょっと…
やばいぞ
スフィア（球体）モードにしたやつですよね
所沢ってどこで買えるの？
どうせ、次また俺の可能性もあるから
僕の可能性もふまえた上で
えっと、なんて言ってったっけこのコメント、覚えてんだよな…
髪型、変！とか
あああああっ
「あ～」って？！
いきます！
フフフフ
また本人
自分が多いですね
最近の動画にしよ、最近の動画
23歳男性。初めてのコンタクトレンズ
これもなんか割と読みやすい気もしますなー
あっ！きた、俺分かったよ
ほんとに？
メガネのはじめんも好き///
グフフフ
コンタクトつけてる人グッドボタン
絶対これでしょ
おおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおい
俺しかいないじゃ～ん！
こんばんわ！　ふざけんじゃねぇぞマジで…
ああ！でもでも次だ！　二番目がそうだったね
惜しくね？
いや～惜しかったね。僕を除けば合ってましたね
線香花火1200本まとめて燃やせばロマンチックなのか？
火事や…
ああ、なるほどね
いや、これこそ最近の流行りだよこれは
このコメントにグッドした人は明日告白される
いきます！　はい
ハハハハハ
ちょっとセンスある
これはね、やられた
血液検査したら結果がよろしくなかった
ラーメンやめたから、良くなるんじゃねぇ？みたいな
また一年お菓子禁止だね。みたいな
ああー
お菓子禁止した意味…
でもなそいゆう訳でもないんだよな…
はじめんちょっと太った？みたいな
いきます！　はい
さあ
あああああ、そっちか！！そっちか～！！！
お菓子禁止した意味…でもなそいゆう訳でもないんだよな…
くっそ～
大量の浮く甲羅に乗ればオレも浮ける！（気がする）
これこそ多分ねえ
最近出た動画は、絶対流行りがくるから
このコメントにグッドボタン押した人は明日告白…
乗れないと思った
あ～、なるほどね
いきます！　はい
えっ？
私はhajimeを好きな16歳の女の 字 です。
hajimeあたたは韓国でもとても有名なYouTubeスターです。
私は日本のお菓子も好きで、韓国と日本が仲良く過ごせたら良いと思います。
ありがとうございます
こんな変化球あるか！
嬉しいけど変化球だねぇ
誕生日に1人で部屋にいたら誰か来てくれるのか？
もう「誕生日おめでとう」でしょう！
おめでとう
俺がめっちゃ忙しくて来てないから
「まさき来ないんだ」
その可能性もあるぞ
いきましょ、いきましょ
いきまーす
アッハハハハハ
片思い中の人、挙手！
俺の誕生日だよぉ…
やばいぞ、そろそろ当てよう。　ちょっと本気で…